hello sir good evening so you are here
to audition for the lead role in white
house down are you not yes that's right
I am i was really really hope i can be
in this movie it looks exciting it looks
fun I was really hoping I'd be in it do
you have any prior acting experience um
I mean I do skits on YouTube and stuff
you know hmm I mean I just really feel
like I'd be right for the role I just I
honestly do do you think White House
down is a ripoff of Olympus has fallen
no they're not similar nice try it's not
going to give you the job you have any
weapons training
um no any training at all in regards to
acting no do you have muscles number one
you're not that big number two don't
ever do that again number three Channing
Tatum's muscles are bigger so we hired
him goodbye
well guys in a movie filled with
well-dressed men Secret Service agents
and Channing Tatum's muscles I didn't
feel right doing this review unless I
looked my best white house down is
directed by Roland Emmerich this guy is
famous for independence day' godzilla'
the day after tomorrow the Patriot
anonymous 10,000 BC and 2012 he's made
some other films too but those are
really the big ones he's kind of like
the go-to guy for these big gigantic
movies where the White House blows up
because that's essentially what this
movie is about terrorists trying to take
over the White House Channing Tatum is
the one guy in the White House who
couldn't get the Secret Service job that
he wanted so now he has to prove that he
can save the president from these
terrorists as well as his daughter who
is also trapped in the White House I
can't do this review without mentioning
that this movie literally is Olympus
it's fallen I mean it's just basically
the exact same film in a different way
I'm not the guy who's gonna say I know
which idea came first I actually did
look it up and I couldn't really find
any information aside from the fact that
both of the production companies that
compete while making this movie but
they're pretty much the same movie
except with slightly different twists
and turns and they are and obviously a
different directorial style so Channing
Tatum plays the die-hard like John
McClane in this movie who's the one guy
in the White House who can get it done
and Jimmie Foxx plays the
more-than-capable president
and they have really good chemistry with
each other in this movie and I thought
they worked off each other extremely
well and that is probably my favorite
part of this movie was actually the
chemistry between Channing Tatum and
Jamie Foxx and those two characters and
their interplay the movie as a whole is
really dumb it's it's really stupid
unfortunately and I knew that going in
because you know roland emmerich
although I really do like Independence
Day and I really do like the Patriot
which is my favorite film of his he has
a way of making films that can be so
cheesy and so over the top and so overly
dramatic that it causes many I role
sessions and this movie had a lot of
those so I was just like no no no they
did it they did it and they did it again
see there are certain aspects of this
movie that are really well done namely
the action in the film the action the
film I thought was really great like
they did a really great job filming it
there was no stupid shaky-cam you could
tell a lot of the actors are doing their
own stunts there were good action scenes
in the film there were good performances
in the movie this movie is filled with
great actors Channing Tatum Jamie Foxx
James Woods Richard Jenkins the dude
whose name I always forget from zero
dark thirty there's a lot of really good
actors in this movie and everyone does a
pretty good job with the material that
they're given it's just that's what I'm
saying they do a good job with the
material that they're given because
sometimes the material they're given is
really weak and that comes from the
script from James Vanderbilt who also
wrote The Rundown starring the rock
darkness falls a really terrible horror
film and oddly enough he wrote the film
zodiac which i think is a masterpiece by
David Fincher the little girl from Dark
Knight Rises plays Channing Tatum's
daughter in this movie and she just
wasn't she wasn't ready for this movie
because there are some crying scenes and
there are some whimpering scenes that
just were bad just not quite ready for
the material that was given her and
perhaps Direction wasn't entirely in her
favor because not really working was her
performance I just turned into Yoda not
really working was her performance sorry
the movie features tons and tons of
really cliched military dialogue that's
so cheesy where you know like okay that
would just never happen like this one
guy who just comes into a room and like
sets up a little device and just
controls the White House all of a sudden
he's like I'm the king of all hackers
everyone prays
me I'm like seriously is just it's just
way too much it's a screenplay that
wants you to have a lot of fun with it
and at times you do the action sequences
are really well done but it also has
this light-hearted sense of humor about
it but then there are times when it
really wants you to take it seriously
like super super seriously but you can't
because it's so over the top the reason
I enjoyed Olympus has fallen was because
it seemed like it had a consistent tone
all the way through it that knew what it
was it wasn't trying to be anything that
it wasn't it seemed like it really got
the idea that this is just a fun action
movie White House down is a fun action
film at times but it seems like it tries
to get too overly serious it is a Roland
Emmerich movie that is for sure it's a
movie that you go into and you're like
okay I'm just going to mindlessly watch
this action and any of the dialogue that
happens I'm just gonna have to deal with
it basically see for me it was like when
the action sequences came they were
exciting
Channing Tatum did a good job in the
lead role I thought Jimmie Foxx did a
great job as the president but whenever
anyone stopped being cute or funny and
tried to be serious with their dialogue
it just failed like it really honestly
seemed like this movie just should have
been 100% guilty-pleasure
action and it tried to be too serious
and for that reason the movie came out
very cheesy to me sometimes I'm gonna
give the White House down a C+ I do
think that it is a fun film that you
could possibly put in and enjoy if you
really don't care about what you're
seeing but if you go into this movie
expecting anything other than the White
House blowing up a lot or Roland
Emmerich making a lot of self
referential jokes then you're going to
be disappointed because I went into this
movie expect nothing and I got in
mindlessly enjoyable film thanks as
always for watching guys when you do see
the film that comes out on June 28th I'm
really happy I was able to do this early
review let me know what you think of it
below thanks as always guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck my niced